[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
daniel what is happening
good to see you bro
nice to meet ya
this is the finished product well really
nearly
nearly nearly no it looks pretty much
funny to me
wow what killing she does though right i
love it crazy
so and also that you both like got an
instagram page
that's really crazy yeah small world
i couldn't believe it yesterday messaged
me oh i saw you in the street oh
okay he says i'm a neighbor of leons i
was like my neighbour is in
you live in middlesbrough next door
crazy wow well show me around
fantastic coffee off oh good
i'm sorry i'm saying to daniel what
crazy character
i was
but it's fabulous isn't it yeah it's
getting there now
have you got a kid at the moment always
this your first how many how many square
rooms
it's about 440 square meters 440 so
what's that square feet it's got
a 4 000 yeah yeah yeah
yeah literally is it a double gaussian
yeah
okay yeah because i think again leon's
going for a single garage doesn't it
yeah that's right i mean i think
because we're the only plot we got a
slightly more room with the
garden on the side as well yeah because
i couldn't wait to take all those
finished right
it's basically just a downstairs toilet
yeah and then in here
is the lounge oh
which is not finished but oh wow
yeah it is a showhand isn't it
you guys must be so happy all right here
we are yeah
just be so happy yeah that's the so
that's why i really like getting a
property now because
i'm basically away from home all the
time yeah so like last year because of
coronavirus i spent
eight weeks in the uk yeah uh the rest
of the times i worked
don't forget though you're already in
property
yeah that's right you know you're a
structural engineer
you've built your own house made quarter
of a million pounds profit on the house
yeah yeah because then when you're
trying to package and sell deals and
stuff
that's right rather you think i'm just
starting not starting out
yeah you just built a freaking house
yeah that's true you know so it's almost
just like your story
play everyone
[Music]
yes yeah very little steel yeah yeah
but that's just his taste isn't it
that's right yeah this is
very homeless yeah i think so
london and then this will be our master
bedroom
look at this my goodness
it's just such an open spacious
yep yeah this will be a master bedroom
when we get out of the bed
so you can't be living yeah living here
though without a bed
so we're just barely all right yeah
it looks like absolutely immaculate
so nice such a big ensuite yeah
whose idea was it then to do the
instagram page
was it how did that's been going really
well you've got like 26 27
000 followers just solely on the
self build page i was like wow when you
messaged me yesterday i saw
something i was looking through i need
to get in there you know as i'm in the
area and you're on the academy
yeah i thought i can't go home because
middles was so far from
london but i'm gonna have to swing by
are you really excited to be i know
you've already moved in but like moved
and moved in
[Music]
you guys are so neat and tidy
considering i just came around pretty
much pretty much uninvited
unexpected well it was a bit hectic last
night cleaning it up
oh thank you didn't have to guys but
it'll be nice for the cameras
and then this is the nursery
do you know if it's gonna be a boy or a
girl
this is still in progress but this we
want to see a cinema room
it's like a six bedroom no
yeah there's six beds in there yeah so
there's a floor upstairs as well yeah
[Music]
okay in case you felt like a different
room
it wasn't it was going to be a bedroom
initially yeah
and everything we'll just leave it to
from the lights really
yeah what um
and it's quite nice if if we ever did
sell the house and
if people had like teenagers or
something it's like a flaw that they
could have
themselves you know with like a sitting
area and then bedrooms yeah
do you think you'll live here is this
like a potential forever home or what do
you reckon
if you want to do a new one do you
i know we will live here i think we'll
we'll leave here for a
full year at least tomorrow and then we
want to do another one
i think what when um you know
sometimes when people build their own
houses you know the
number 250 that was spent 400 on it but
then the end value 650.
that's right and it's like well there's
not one no there's another one
this is just a mirror yeah yeah
so this looks nice and it's basically
yeah it's really nice
[Music]
bye